hey guys my name is Jess matal it's the
nineteenth of me today and you are tuned
into games what news first up today
Major Nelson has said that they are not
going to be discontinuing the Kinect but
then again they also said they weren't
going to unbundle it from the Xbox one
so I guess we'll see how it goes during
his latest podcast xboxes Major Nelson
said that the decision to make the
Kinect not compulsory was mainly about
giving consumers a choice he says we're
not discontinuing connect or support for
it we still have a whole team of folks
working on that but we want to give
everybody who would like to get in on
the Xbox one action and opportunity let
me know whether you think the Kinect
will swim or sink as a result of the
unbundling reportedly YouTube and by
extension Google are all set to bite
which for 1 billion dollars but the Wall
Street Journal reckons this one might
not happen after all the news came from
sources familiar with the pact we spoke
to Variety it hasn't been confirmed yet
but the report indicates that Google is
getting ready for us regulators to
challenge the acquisition the challenge
could come about as a result of YouTube
already being the most popular platform
to internet videos thereby threatening
the competitive online video market by
acquiring twitch but other publications
like a wall street journal is saying we
shouldn't arm ourselves with pitch books
just yet as it's probably not gonna
happen well Spencer head of Xbox set a
bunch of things on Twitter today and
here are the highlights he thinks that
RTS games on console is set to make a
resurgence which may be relevant since a
job listing on max loves career page
called for someone to help build and
lead the team for a new triple a title
within an established and well-loved
strategy game franchise whether this
falls into the franchise's of age of
empires Halo Wars or something else
entirely remains to be seen among his
other comments he said that the company
is making progress on an xbox one
controller for pc and the wall microsoft
are very focused on pc those
announcements will come after e3 the
National Resources Defense Council has
posted a new report saying that the ps4
and xbox one can seem a hell of a lot of
energy author of the report p
dell forge told USA Today we don't have
a problem with people playing games but
the problem is the amount of energy used
when not playing a game allegedly the
energy consumption increase has come
from new features that rely on the
standby or sleep modes such as how the
xbox one can be turned on with a voice
command which gobbles up 15 watts of
continuous power on standby the nrdc
have projected that if all last gen
consoles are replaced with this
generations models they will use 10
million kilowatt-hours of electricity a
year which is about the same as for
large power plants out of the three new
gen consoles the wii u was the only one
to reduce its energy consumption using
less than 1 watt in standby let me know
in that commenting section down below
whether or not you're surprised about
the power consumption levels of the ps4
and xbox one that is all the things that
I have to tell you about today but I'll
be back tomorrow with a bunch more new
so I hope to see you then